hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing all four of the brand new
colors of the ipad mini i am so excited
to check these all out not only do i
love the new colors but this ipad mini
has been completely redesigned also
bonus this is the other ipad that they
announced at the apple event so we're
also going to unbox this and check it
out but there will be a separate video
featuring this one entirely the new ipad
mini comes in four colors we have the
purple starlight space gray and pink all
right let's open up the pink one first
because obviously pink is my favorite
color
[Music]
you
look
so nice the pink this year is a very
light pink like if i didn't know that
this was pink i might not actually know
that it was pink so this is the ipad air
in the
i guess was it rose gold isn't even pink
either it's more of like a peachy kind
of color let's see what else is in here
look at this little ipad mini document
nice document very nice document so the
ipad mini does come
with a charging brick that's exciting
it's also usbc i feel like the reason
they did this because there was a really
good chance that people who are getting
this ipad mini may not have one of these
usb-c bricks and it has a usb-c to usb-c
cable do you know why the ipad mini is
now usbc it also has touch id like what
this is what i wanted in an iphone
hello
let's check out the purple one this is
more of like a lavender kind of color at
least that's what it looked like online
i hope that it matches my shirt
okay it doesn't
really match my shirt it's more of like
a bluish purple whereas this is kind of
like a lavender this is gonna look
really good with the purple case that i
have over here i do also have some
accessories and another exciting thing
is the ipad mini now supports the apple
pencil generation 2 so you will be able
to use the newest version of the apple
pencil which is one of my favorite
things not only for using for the ipad
but it also makes a really great way to
tie up my hair compared to the pink oh
these colors look so good together on to
the next one it's also great because
these now support 5g so if you get a 5g
sim card and you get the cellular
version you'll be able to basically have
internet anywhere so this will kind of
be like a phone a big phone
okay this one looks really nice too they
all look really good
graphite is unboxed one more to go this
is the color that i'm kind of excited to
see because this is a new one that they
announced called starlight
so let's take a look
oh
look at this
so it might be hard to tell on camera
it's silver but it does have like a
slight little hue
of gold i really like this
[Music]
and here they are here's all four colors
i don't really know if i can pick a
favorite as much as i love the pink i
think i'm gonna go with the purple i
think that's gonna be our review unit
and then we have the 9th gen ipad that
they announced and this is the most
affordable ipad that you can get on the
market it does still have the old design
but it has been updated and refreshed i
do just kind of want to show it to you
just so you guys can see the other
options out there
[Music]
so here it is it pretty much just looks
like one of the older ipads it does
still have touch id and it looks
just like an ipad i will be doing a
follow-up video on this one so be sure
to subscribe hit the bell so you'll be
notified when that goes live we also
have some of the ipad mini smart folios
we have them in three different colors
electric orange dark cherry and english
lavender
now this is pretty i like this a lot it
is kind of almost the same exact color
as this but it looks different because
this is so shiny
it's so cute
it's so cute look at this oh i love it
oh this dark cherry actually looks
really good too this is going to be a
tough choice on which one i want to put
on the purple for the review i feel like
this dark cherry actually looks
great on this pink dark cherry i'm a big
fan
and last we have our electric orange
this is
pretty aggressive
wow
let's put that on
graphite shall we
these look great i'm so excited about
the ipad mini i feel like there is so
much power in this little tiny device so
here it is this is the all-new ipad mini
with 5g four new colors second gen apple
pencil support upgraded cameras touch id
usbc 40 faster cpu 8.3 inch display and
all running on the new ipad os 15.
[Music]
so the first thing that you're going to
notice about the new ipad mini is this
much larger display it's now edge to
edge where the previous mini still had
the touch id on the bottom this is
pretty much game changing as far as
ipads are concerned because the ipad
mini is now powerful enough to be a real
consideration when deciding which ipad
you'd want for doing more processor
intensive tasks this also has center
stage like the ipad pro with this new
wide-angle camera if you're doing
facetime calls it will keep you in the
center of focus now i really loved when
they added this in the new ipad pros so
i'm so excited that that's an option
that they have on here
do you see center stage do you see what
i'm doing
no that's actually not a lightsaber
that's just that's um that's set
decoration
one thing that i really wish they would
do is move the camera up here to the top
because for me this is technically the
top but for apple i feel like this is
what they consider the top because most
of the time i'm usually using my ipad
horizontally like this and it makes for
such a better eye line if it's on the
top either way with center stage at
least that'll help keep you in the frame
properly when you're doing your face
time calls with facetime and the new
ipad os 15 you'll be able to do share
play so you can watch movies listen to
music you can share your screen and do
so much more just over face time
together facetime links is also
something new in both ios and ipad os
15. so this will let you invite your
friends using a web link to join a call
no matter what device you're on now the
camera on the back is also new it has a
12 megapixel sensor with focus pixels so
you'll be able to get sharper and higher
quality shots now i would not say that
this is a device to get if you were
really serious about taking mobile
photos but with a new front and back
camera it's a huge update from the last
ipad mini this will shoot 4k videos but
again you are limited to that one wide
angle lens for anything that you might
be filming you can also now use the
second gen apple pencil which is very
exciting because i love the design of
this pencil so much more than the
previous it has a matte finish and this
edge will let you get a better grip of
it and it could dock to your ipad for
immediate charging and connection you'll
probably remember that last gen and how
silly it was to charge with a lightning
port sticking out of the side of your
ipad i mean that's basically a site that
no one could ever forget drawing on the
ipad always feels like such a magical
experience and i'm not an illustrator
but i have definitely had such a fun
time messing around in procreate i'm so
impressed with how many talented people
have created so many beautiful
masterpieces on these devices the one
thing that i found myself using the
apple pencil for is creating quick notes
now on ipad os you'll be able to swipe
up from the corner to instantly create a
quick note you can also add tags and
mentions inside of notes now and this is
so great for making things even more
searchable through a tag browser it's so
awesome now that everything in your
camera roll is automatically converted
to text so you can interact with it and
search i have been using this so much on
the ios 15 beta on my phone for copying
phone numbers and even searching for
things that i know that i took a photo
of and there was text in the scene since
this is now usbc you can plug in
accessories and even charge through the
port i mentioned it before but i will
say it again that i really thought that
this was a precursor to the iphone this
year having usb-c maybe this means that
we'll be seeing it next year in iphone
14 or maybe we won't even see a port at
all it's really hard to say this does
have wi-fi six along with 5g which is
actually really exciting i know that
everyone is always talking about 5g and
for a lot of you guys you might not even
have really good 5g coverage in your
area i do have 5g but i do not have the
ultra wide band which is
so fast it's so fast that it's actually
quicker for me to get in the car drive
down the street to where ultra wide band
is upload the video which will take like
five seconds and drive back home that
whole process
is quicker than just uploading that
video if i were to just sit here and use
my regular internet anyway there is two
versions of this there is a wi-fi and a
cellular so if you don't plan on getting
a cellular plan for it you can just get
the wi-fi i really love the new
multitasking menu so you can easily
change how you want the layout to be
there's now also a shelf for apps that
have various windows open making it
really easy to select which one you want
being able to add widgets to your ipad
is also really cool there's a lot of
different ones that you can choose from
and of course you can customize the size
to fit the layout that you're going for
there's a new contact widget so you can
use this to easily stay in touch with
people that you chat with the most i
also really like that they have a find
my widget i have so many air tags on all
of my items so i love that i can just
quickly see where all of my stuff is at
i do love that the app library has now
come to the ipad i've loved using this
on my iphone so much because i don't
have to actually have the apps on my
home screen they can just be accessed
from the library instead another feature
that i can't wait to try is universal
control now they announced this back at
wwdc and it's where you'll be able to
bring your mac your ipad or even your
macbook next to each other and you'll be
able to control all three with the same
keyboard and mouse that's going to be so
awesome and i can't wait to try it i am
so excited for all of the new things
that were announced over the past year
and now they are finally actually being
deployed with the new ipads and the
iphones i have a feeling there will be
more apple goodies before the end of
this year is over so be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when i get my hands on them
until then you'll find me on twitter
instagram i'm doing weird stuff on tick
tock i'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
you